bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur tv fil 78 pour un nouveau numéro du
7 8 sociétés vous pouvez réagir je vous
le rappelle et participer et poser
toutes vos questions à nos invités sur
twitter en tapant hashtag 7,8 société en
attend vos commentaires
le thème de ce soir après la mort de
moussa quelles leçons à tirer moussa
c'est ce jeune homme de 14 ans tué lors
d'une fusillade à trappes le vendredi
1er mai une mort violente qui a suscité
beaucoup de réactions de soutien de
fraternité d'une part mais qui pose
également de nombreuses questions
comment en est on arrivé à ce drame
guerre de territoire sur fond de trafic
de drogue ou simple réalité simple
rivalité pardon de quartier surtout
comment ils mettre fin pour tenter de
répondre à ces questions trois invités à
lire avait tout d'abord maire adjoint
délégué à la jeunesse et aux sports à
trappes bonjour la baie stéphane du
mushi qui est membre du collectif trappe
citoyens élus d'opposition à la mairie
de trappes bonsoir nous sommes dessus et
enfin cheikh oumar mbaye secrétaire
général adjoint à la solidarité donc
solidarité haïti c'est une association
de coopération de bon soir alors pour
commencer cette émission on va revenir
peut-être sur cet événement messieurs
comment avec vous tout simplement vécu
ces événements à trappes et puis comment
avez vous reçu également le retour des
habitants à lire avait peut-être pour
commencer
écoutez moi j'étais adjoint de
permanence savait que les adjoints se
relayent toute l'année pour être de
permanence pour pouvoir parer à toute
urgence donc les pompiers m'ont appelé
m'ont invité à me rendre sur les lieux
au moins non sans une fusillade est la
blessure grave d'un enfant de trappes je
me suis rendu immédiatement sur place et
j'ai dû organiser un certain nombre de
choses contact avec la famille
évidemment les discussions avec les
jeunes qui étaient présents en nombre
discussions avec la police également
qu'ils étaient sur les lieux et comment
vous dire comment j'ai vécu ça c'est des
circonstances que je des moments que je
ne souhaite à personne d'avoir à vivre
et à gérer évidemment
j'étais aux côtés de la famille toute la
soirée je multiplie les allers-retours
entre les lieux du drame l'hôpital où la
famille attendait le verdict et les
échanges avec les jeunes également assez
rapidement une dizaine d'animateurs de
la ville sont arrivés pour pouvoir
échanger avec les jeunes présents
pouvoir faire le tour des familles et on
a fait on a commencé immédiatement à se
mettre en contact avec les familles du
quartier pour partager leurs sentiments
s'assurer que les appels au calme se
multiplier et j'ai vécu évidemment cette
soirée aux côtés de la famille en
particulier de la mer de moussa sow
resté très digne ces extrêmes dignité en
permanence je pense en particulier aux
frères et soeurs de mon sac est
également à l'hôpital et qui attendaient
le retour des médecins donc j'ai vécu
cette séquence très douloureuse à leurs
côtés et je vous disais donc très grande
dignité de leur part évidemment
au moment où le médecin a annoncé la
mort de moussa très grande dignité
également le lendemain quand ils ont
souhaité puisque des familles du
quartier ont très vite souhaité se
retrouver se réunir discuter comment
c'est également le travail de deuil
quand on a appris la mort de moussa on a
organisé dès le lendemain à 14h un
premier rassemblement avec des familles
de plusieurs quartiers de la ville
d'ailleurs notamment avec la star du
square le lendemain de la mort de ce
lendemain de la troisième qui a réuni
plus d'une centaine de personnes dans un
espace jeunes et quelques centaines de
personnels extérieurs qui ont souhaité
se réunir d'abord pour rendre un premier
hommage à moussa pour partager le deuil
collectivement dans le silence et la
dignité et il y en avait un la voir se
lance alors je vous préparer pour
préparer la marche moi je vous coupe
excusez moi les rabais puisque nous
avons par téléphone le hic travers a
délégué régional ile-de-france des
syndicats de police alliance que nous
avons donc en direct par téléphone
bonsoir monsieur travers
alors pourriez-vous tout d'abord nous
parler de la situation que certains
décrivent comme tendu on a d'abord parlé
de cette possibilité comme étant la
cause principale de la fusillade une
tension une rivalité entre deux
quartiers de trappes qui pourraient être
à l'origine vous nous en dire un petit
peu plus
bas c'est à dire qu'elle enquête est
encore un petit peu prématuré de tenter
d'établir un mobile il est évident
effectivement que c'est quelque chose
qui peut ne pas être écartée c'est à
dire une situation de bandes rivales
suite à un conflit personnel suite à une
bagarre suite pourquoi pas une affaire
de stupéfiants un règlement de compte
venir voilà aujourd'hui on a tout eu
toute une possibilité tout un panel et
le but pour les enquêteurs de négliger
aucune piste dès le début et de ne
surtout pas se focaliser sur tel ou tel
souci une telle ou telle possibilité nos
confrères de bayel de balayer large et
le but c'est avec toutes les
constatations qui ont été faites le jour
du crime et aussi avec l'analyse des
différents témoignages de l'entourage du
voisinage mais également tout travail de
recoupement dans le cadre de
rapprochement judiciaire sur des faits
similaires elle va de trouver petit à
petit une piste qui se resserre sur un
mobile précis mais aujourd'hui il faut
faire attention c'est dangereux de
commencer à dire que c'est telle ou
telle piste pas seul effectivement la
suite de la requête pourra vraiment
d'établir d'une façon précise c'est pour
ça que j'ai précisé luc travers une des
raisons éventuelles d'un fusillade où on
est aux enquêtes pour l'instant
pour le sport c'est le srpj de
versailles qui qui diligente une enquête
d'accord et on en est vraiment dans le
travail de fond comme je le disais tout
à l'heure c'est à dire l'exploitation de
tous les témoignages de ce qu'on appelle
enquête de voisinage l'entourage des
personnes qui sont concernées de près ou
de loin par cette enquête il ya un
travail de constatations qui a été fait
sur place il faut espérer que les biens
des traces et indices étaient soit
exploitable afin de pouvoir orienter
leurs piètres tout simplement donc là on
est devant le travail en fait de fra
lignée des peu des policiers pour tenter
le faire éclater la vérité alors les
fourgons notamment de gendarmerie sont
présents un petit peu partout attrapons
ce moment la police crainte est le dd
vengeance des représailles particulière
alors
l'idée effectivement que ce soit pour la
police mais aussi pour d'autres
structures que ce soit le nombre de la
mairie et c'est là le but c'est d'éviter
effectivement une surenchère donc l'idée
de la police là c'est d'occuper le
terrain évidemment avec des moyens peut
être un petit peu plus conséquent que
d'habitude mais en tout cas avec des
patrouilles un peu plus diriger un but
le but c'est de le clairement faire un
travail de prévention important bien
pour éviter grâce aux patrouilles de
sécurité publique renforcés à la
présence des gendarmes en des crf est
bien d'éviter le fait que ça puisse
devenir un affrontement permanent où des
rixes permanent le but là c'est
clairement il faire en sorte qu'il ya
une sérénité qu'ils soient
qui soit la règle de maintenir le calme
et d'éviter toute sorte de surenchère et
notamment comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure
alors le il traverse stéphane du mushi à
une question à vous poser et haïr avait
également qu'ils sont présents avec mon
plateau stéphane de moucher d'abord oui
monsieur travers lors des échauffourées
de 2013 monsieur valls avait annoncé un
dispositif la zone d'une zone de
sécurité prioritaire et je voulais
simplement savoir ce que cela avait
amené en termes de conditions de travail
en termes d'effectifs supplémentaires ou
policiers de la ville de trappes alors
malheureusement à cette question elle
nous est souvent imposé sur toutes les
zones de sécurité les espèces qui ont
été on va dire créer sur l'ensemble de
la france et plus particulièrement à
trappes nous déplorons qu'on titre du
syndicat alliance police nationale et
bien qu'il n'y ait pas eu de moyens
supplémentaires mais ils ont un effectif
et un budget meilleur matériel c'est à
dire que effectivement il ya un effet
d'annonce dans le cadre de ces zones de
sécurité prioritaire mais qui n'ont pas
été suivies et bien de choses on va dire
concrètes en termes d'équipement de
moyens pour renforcer surtout les
effectifs et faire le travail de
prévention adéquates dans ce type de
secteur effectivement c'est un fait un
gros problème qu'on a dénoncé batimat
reprise et sur lequel nous n'avons pas
été entendus et qui a
qui a par ailleurs
perdurer aussi dans d'autres endroits en
ile-de-france mais plus généralement
aussi en province dernière question des
travers de dali rabais adjoint une
première remarque avant une question
concrète d'abord dire que j'apprécie
votre prudence quant aux quant au cours
de l' enquête évidemment à l
identification des suspects de la
fusillade il faut toujours être prudent
dans les déclarations surtout quand on
est très sollicité par les journalistes
d'ailleurs de ce point de vue je
regrette que dans le feu de l'action les
premières heures dans les commentaires
médiatiques vous ayez laissé entendre
que la femme que le jeune daouda qui a
été blessé lors de la fusillade a été
gravement blessé il faut se garder de ce
genre de commentaire parce que les
familles qui attendent de savoir comment
va leur enfant peuvent évidemment être
perturbée si elles savent que une source
jean une source qui s'expriment
découvert annonce une blessure grave là
où effectivement la blessure était
heureusement pour david haye sa famille
superficielles j'en profite également
produire un mot particulier pour daouda
qui était présent à la manifestation à
la grande marche blanche et qui
évidemment a subi des séquelles en
dehors de des blessures physiques qui
sont psychologiques des séquelles
psychologiques assez sérieuse je vous
pose une question également non pas au
sujet de la z sp des résultats mais
plutôt au sujet de la police de
proximité qui a été supprimée vous le
savez maintenant il ya plus de quinze
ans par nicolas sarkozy cette police de
proximité dont on a besoin à trappes
puisqu'il ya aujourd'hui des fourgons de
crs et des véhicules qui sont
massivement présents à trappes ça
contribue aussi à rassurer la population
qui nous le dit mais on a besoin non pas
pendant quinze jours mais durablement
d'une police qui connaissent les
habitants qui circulent à pied dans la
ville et qui soit capable d'identifier
les fauteurs de troubles et de ne pas
ramasser au chalut tous les jeunes de
trappes contient une difficulté qu'est
ce quelle est la position d'autres
indications laissent leurs travers on
laisse lectra vers répondu on précise
que ce retrait d'ici là les rabais on a
toujours précisé que daoud a été
légèrement blessé luc travers on vous
laisse répondre
sur le premier point la gravité des
blessures effectivement ce n'était
certainement pas la surenchère
médiatique mais elle est bel et bien une
blessure effectivement que l'on peut
considérer
comme grave eu égard notamment au type
d'armes utilisé d'accord on sache que
peut faire un tir en rafale en termes de
dégâts et notamment quand il s'agit de 9
mm c'est tout simplement les raisons qui
ont conduit effectivement à ce mot
peut-être un petit peu fort pour vous
mais qui effectivement avait quand même
donné lieu par ailleurs à quelqu'un qui
était décédé effectivement il ya quand
même une gravité qui était assez
importante le deuxième point pour la
prise de proximité et notamment sur les
moyens des bleus qui ont été mis en
place à l'époque que vous avez cités moi
je vais être beaucoup plus loin que ça
parce que jeune policier en 1999 j'ai
participé à la mise en place de la
police de proximité à l'époque de
monsieur chevènement et c'était déjà la
même problématique que pour les aider ce
pays c'est à dire que l'on avait des
missions avec des endroits bien défini
donc c'était assez précis assez carré on
va dire il est à côté de ça eh bien on
n'avait absolument pas les moyens pour
ce faire je me souviens moi à l'époque
comme un problème est qu'on avait un
effectif dans le monde non mais l'unité
à l'époque où nous étions arrivés argent
d'un coup et nous n'avions pas les
véhicules pour patrouiller il ya des
batteries des véhicules qui avaient été
empruntés surtout des services de france
et de navarre pour justement faire en
sorte que l'ile-de-france au niveau de
la mise en place de la police de
proximité
et bien ce soit clairement recadrer donc
déjà à l'époque et en 1989 mais après
aussi on a eu cette problématique
effectivement du manque de moyens à
l'occasion et bien des annonces faites à
grand renfort de publicité de la mise en
place de la police de proximité alors
ils sont et je finirai pour pour pour
par dire quelque chose qui est quand
même important
c'était un petit peu souligné tout tout
à l'heure on a là un fait particulier
sur train d'accord c'est à dire qu'on
n'a pas une résurgence de ce type de
problématique depuis trois mois pas le
cas on a là l'utilisation d'une arme
automatique en rafales de type nas mm
avec certainement une envie de blesser
voire de tuer puisque malheureusement
c'est l'un des dégâts on a une rapidité
de l'action et là on a quelque chose de
qui est qui ressemble à un fait nouveau
d'accord quand on voit qu'on peut se
passer dans d'autres endroits en france
et notamment je parle plus
particulièrement du 93 ou des mamans ont
défilé effectivement à savoir nous
sommes les maîtres violence et de
pratiques de l'équipe devions il est
évident je partage l'idée de la personne
qui vient de s'exprimer qu'il faut
surtout pas que ça se généralise et
j'espère que ça va rester à fait
particulier et qu'elle va être joli
merci en tout cas à luc travers je
rappelle que vous êtes délégué régional
d'ile-de-france du syndicat de police
alliance merci de vous être rendu
disponible
bonne soirée au revoir au revoir cher
vous voulez vous liez romarin by réagir
sur ce que vient de dire que tous les
travers et lyon la situation globale et
sur les solutions qu'il faudrait
apporter également pour sortir pour
sortir de tous la trappe ou moi je
voulais toujours revenir sur ce dossier
sur ce point de police de proximité
ouais parce que je vois que même s'il
n'y a pas cette police de proximité
on pouvait quand même avoir une
possibilité de ces policiers se
permettre de se rapprocher de ces
jeunes-là
d'avoir en moins de dialoguer avec ces
jeunes que de les voir juste courir
entre eux et ça pourrait faciliter la
tâche ça pourrait permettre un dialogue
comprendre ces jeunes avant que c'était
la série arrive dans la ville donc là il
ya une grande un grand écart donc les
jeunes il fit tous les jours les
policiers et ça je crois que le fait de
crier quand même en système de dialogue
avec ces jeunes ne sera possible de ces
jeunes là ça permettrait quand même de
faciliter la tâche ou encadrer des
problèmes et ça c'est pas quelque chose
qui met en place stéphane de mushie n'y
a aucun lien entre la police et les
habitants où est ce que la mairie selon
vous faciliter ces échanges
c'est pas mal de le dire c'est plutôt à
monsieur rabais non mon sentiment alors
pas forcément d'élus mais de citoyens et
vous a quand même en conseil municipal
oui je conseil municipal mais pas
seulement parce que devant ce qui s'est
passé
de deux choses choc et émotion un choc
en tant qu'élu émotions en tant qu'élu
mais pas seulement choquée émotions en
tant que habitants de trappes mais pas
seulement chaque émotion en tant que
père
en tant que père qui se dit mais est-ce
que cela n'aura arrive est arrivé à mes
enfants ou ma famille ou à mes voisins
ou à mes proches et à mes amis je veux
pas faire dans le sensationnel mais
quand même c'est une question qui se
pose
depuis que que ces événements ont eu
lieu j'entends ici ou là des
commentaires politiques qui moi me ne me
conviennent pas par exemple j'entends
par exemple le maire de trappes qui
explique ce qui est bien lancé guy
malandain ce qui s'est passé et est
causée par un déficit d'éducation ou un
déficit
d'implication des parents dans
l'éducation de leurs enfants je suis
désolé monsieur malanda l'on n'a pas
affaire à une incivilité on a affaire à
un meurtre un homicide commis comme
rappelé monsieur travers à l'armé lourde
à l'armé automatique à une arme de
guerre une arme de grand banditisme et
ça faut en prendre conscience donc à
lire avant d'ajouter c'est la faute de
les parents sonneront du malandain je
vais vous dire samedi quand on s'est
réuni avec les familles c'est un membre
de la famille de moussa qui a pris la
parole et qui a interrogé c'était
légitime ou pas là qui est sous la
responsabilité des parents dans la
surenchère dans les affrontements dans
les bagarres qui ont fait ressortir qui
a été posée je n'ai pas entendu guy
malandain dire ce que les propos que je
viens entendent mais moi je ne suis pas
là pour polémiquer sur ce qu'a dit ou
pas dit guy malandain c'est tout ce que
je vous disais un membre de la famille a
tenu ce discours on est tous interrogés
par ce qui s'est passé et on est tous
convoqués pour réfléchir aux solutions
non pas pour éviter que ça se reproduise
parce que personne n'a la baguette
magique pour éviter que ça se reproduise
et qu'un enfant de trappes moeurs si
quelqu'un là c'est un menteur ou alors
qu'il la présente en public on est tous
convoqués pour essayer de réfléchir aux
causes et aux solutions et évidemment
pour certaines familles
de désengagement des familles est un
problème il faut voir comment la société
peut répondre à cela à travers des
dispositifs publics et travers
l'engagement de la communauté des
trappistes non pas le communautarisme
justement mais l'engagement de
l'ensemble des trappistes ce que vous
faites par exemple accueille 10 dans
votre association et compris avec vos
jeunes un mois vous avez organisé les
manifestations et la jeunesse de trappes
c'est une façon d'impliquer les parents
les enfants les jeunes eux-mêmes pour
organiser la solidarité dans cette ville
mener des actions de solidarité
internationale c'est le cas pour kaédi
au niveau de la commune de trappes et
pour qu'on se protège les uns les autres
finalement et c'est aussi ce qui s'est
passé pendant la marche silencieuse de
lundi c'est plus de 2000 personnes se
sont rassemblées pour se sécuriser les
uns les autres pour investir le terrain
également pour dire que tu rappes nous
appartient les rues trappe nous
appartiennent et que nous ne tolèrerons
pas des villes où c'est accepter ou
c'est quasiment quotidien nous ne
tolérerons pas usage d'armes à feu
attrape moi je suis pas là pour
polémiquer sur qui a dit quoi alors
justement pour éviter de polémiquer je
veux dans un et solutions merci quelles
sont les solutions que vous proposez que
ce soit vous lira b à la mairie stéphane
du mushi c'est bien celle d une réaction
de pères qui se posent des questions
alors évidemment on peut mettre ça sur
sur le terrain de la politique mais
c'est une écharpe un échappatoire pour
laisser toujours se débat dans l'émotion
effectivement faut trouver des solutions
mais les solutions elles se trouvent pas
que dans des des dispositifs qui
finalement ne font pas leurs effets
parce qu'il n'y a pas les moyens
derrière on parle monsieur travers parlé
tout à l'heure de la dcn de sécurité est
prioritaire et pour vous donc ne sert à
rien
elle servirait à quelque chose si on
mettait les moyens qu'il fallait
voilà on peut alors j'entendais
justement monsieur hamon dire que la
zone
urbaine prioritaires fonctionnait
parfaitement alors là je pars entrée non
plus dans la polémique mais on n'est pas
justement période de
d'autosatisfaction on est dans une
période où on doit se poser des
questions et peut-être remettre en cause
des solutions et d
et mettre en place des évaluations pour
savoir ce qui fonctionne et ce qui ne
fonctionne pas car manger quoi c'est
important aussi de faire des journées de
sensibilisation comme vient de le dire
parce que ces gens là quand il voit
quand même une histoire de l'école à
l'âge très jeune et ça c'est très
important confusion qui les trouvent
dans les rangs des bâtiments à l'âge de
14 ans 15 ans
devant un bâtiment à l'âge de 95 ans
saisonnier ils ont déjà ils ont déjà il
est chef de l'école il a rempli non pas
de formation ils n'y peuvent pas aller à
l'école et de quand ils se retrouvent
comme ça devant les bâtiments toute la
journée il ce fort probable qu'ils se
construisent d'autres choses qui sont
pas bons donc quand je vois l'état doit
aussi agir sur sa éviter que ces jeunes
là se trouve que c'est à cet âge là
c'est le trouve dans la rue et que ses
parents il séduit parce que la plupart
des ces jeunes là aussi les parents
n'ont pas fait de l'école ils n'ont pas
beaucoup d'expérience il cire la vie que
si je ne la font dans les cités donc
aussi à l'état de venir à l'aide donc
quand on laisse ces gens là juste avec
les parents ils vont jamais s'en sortir
parce que s'ils ont déjà l'échec de
l'école à l'âge de 14 ans donc c'est
pareil ils n'ont pas assez de moins pour
permettre à ces jeunes là d'aller dans
des grandes écoles d'un couvent le seul
souci qui se trouve c'est de se
retrouver dans des démons du bâtiment et
tout ça et ça c'est quelque chose qui va
se construire une mauvais chemin et que
l'état viendra après alors qu'il aurait
dû être là avant alors justement il
rappeler comment on fait concrètement
pour éviter que des jeunes reste à
stationner on va dire d'avoir déjà tout
petit mot sur la z sp moi je suis pas
l'avocat du ministère de l'intérieur moi
je pense qu'il faut des effectifs de
police toujours plus nombreux dans des
villes comme trappe et surtout qu'ils
soient des policiers de proximité
moi je veux pas qu'on me rétablisse le
même dispositif 197 sais pas ce qui
m'intéresse ce qui m'intéresserait c'est
de voir des policiers à pied en vélo
comme de police municipale qui circulent
au milieu des habitants qui existent
soit repéré par les habitants après ce
qui ne s'est pas la trappe la police
municipale à pied à trappes c'est le cas
mais la police nationale on aimerait le
maire le sollicite systématiquement en
conseil local de sécurité de prévention
de la délinquance des effectifs plus
nombreux et qui circulent au milieu de
la population à pied comme dans
certaines villes de ce pays et des
équipages qui ne circule qu'en voiture
c'est bien ça donne de la visibilité
mais un policier en tenue au milieu de
la ville c'est ça qui rassure les
habitants en allant acheter sa baguette
vous pouvez croiser un policier qui
circulent au centre commercial en même
temps que vous sur ce qui est fait il
faut aussi parler de ce qui est fait
bien je parlais tout à l'heure de
l'association qui a éduqué active auprès
d'eux des trappistes en particulier des
jeunes
juste pour moussa en particulier il
était n'ont pas traîné en bas de chez
lui toute la journée et c'est moussa
c'est un enfant qui évidemment était en
vacances je vous rappelle que ces faits
ont eu lieu pendant les vacances donc un
enfant à 15 1 15 heures à l'extérieur
dans un an avec ses amis dans son
quartier c'est normal non il est en
vacances il fait beau il ya l'extérieur
premier élément deuxième élément une
semaine avant la première semaine des
congés moussa était maintenant vacant en
auvergne
séjour municipales organisées par là par
la mairie trappe pour la première fois
d'ailleurs nous organisons ce séjour qui
n'est pas un séjour classique nous avons
emmené 54 élèves de troisième uniquement
des élèves de 3e puisqu'il s'agissait de
préparer le brevet des collèges donc
moussa qui devait passer le brevet des
collèges dans un mois préparée pendant
une semaine entre autres activités
préparer le brevet en n'ayant pas moins
de cinq heures de révisions par jour
dont il faisait partie de ces élèves
très sérieux qui voulait mettre toutes
les chances de leur côté pour avoir
leurs brevets et qu'ils révisaient 25
heures en une semaine en cinq jours au
milieu d'activités de loisirs etc avec
des professeurs payés par l'éducation
nationale des profs
donc je vous parlais sur les dispositifs
évidemment il ya ça il ya ya plus de 120
gamins qui participent à
l'accompagnement à la scolarité dans les
espaces jeunes en sortant de l'école ils
vont réviser avec des professeurs pour
maximiser leurs chances d'obtenir des
diplômes il ya heavy plein de
dispositifs comme cela qu'ils organes
qui sont organisés se sera jamais
suffisant il faudra toujours en faire
plus justement c'est ce qu'on vit de ce
point de vue une ville à prendre l'avis
de l'opposition ne cède pas en faire
peut-être mais suffisamment on nous
demande d'en faire l'essai des quartiers
moi je vais on nous demande d'en faire
moins le budget de la ville de trappes
de cette année pour la jeunesse et +30 %
j'aurais aimé que l'opposition je pense
que stéphane du bouche à oreille mais
j'aurais aimé que toute l'opposition
notamment l'ump puisse voter ne serait
ce que pour l'augmentation de 30% du
budget jeunesse on est une des rares
villes en ce moment qu'il n'augmente pas
les impôts qui augmentent le budget pour
la jeunesse c'est des dispositifs
nouveaux courageux qu'on met en place il
faut aussi qu'on ait plus de moyens une
ville comme trappe à qui on baisse les
dotations effectivement mais qui
refusent d'augmenter les impôts parce
que c'est pas le moment d'aller à le
redire la charge pour les trappistes qui
n'ont pas les moyens vous le disais tout
à l'heure mais qui choisi de sacrifier
certains ponts pour mettre un maximum de
budget sur la jeunesse du bauchi
oui alors il ya un problème social et
monsieur rabais a raison de le rappeler
monsieur aussi mais là on est quand même
encore une fois dans un acte extrêmement
violent qui n'est pas que social qui est
qui concerne la sécurité des uns ou des
autres des trappistes qui concerne
l'implication et le professionnalisme de
la police ou en tout cas l'implication
et profits les moyens que l'on donne
pour que cette implication puisse se
faire le problème de trappes c'est
uniquement un problème sécuritaire c'est
qu'il n'ya pas juste assis d'aujourd'hui
il a rien d'autre au jour d'aujourd'hui
lui ce qui s'est passé oui on doit
absolument parler de sécurité est
absolument parler de justice ça fait un
peu plus d'une semaine et plus que que
les événements sont arrivés on a très
peu encore d'éléments pour éclaircir
les causes de cette de summer de cet
assassinat
je pense qu'on est en droit d'exiger un
peu plus de rapidité et j'espère que
monsieur le maire monsieur ravet et les
élus de la majorité vont faire en sorte
que que la justice et la police agissent
au plus vite pour que les familles de
trappes soit soient rassurés ou en tout
cas connaissent les éléments de 2,5 en
cas de cette enquête et les haies et
qu'on en trouve enfin les coupables
sakurai ce dernier portait un endroit
aussi quand on parle aussi de la
sécurité et la justice ge on ne pourra
aussi parler de l'avenir de ces gens là
avant que cela arrive bah c'est qu'il
faut éviter que cela arrive pour parler
de la sécurité et à la prévention tout
pour que ce n'est pas pour que cela
n'arrive pas parce que si cela arrive en
bas après on parle de la sécurité ou de
la justice on aurait bien n'a pas parlé
de ça c'est que ça c'est déjà
attendre les trappistes c'est la paix et
la justice moi j'ai entendu ça dans le
cortège de la marche marche blanche je
n'ai pas entendu que ça j'ai entendu
aussi des expressions de colère et
colère sont l'inquiétude
et là il faut absolument trouver trouver
les coupables au plus vite un dernier
mot de conclusion vraiment rapidement
estimons rapide pour dire
qu'effectivement nous avons tous les
suites de l'enquêté ça va contribuer à
crever un peu les fantasmes personne
n'est capable de dire qui a commis cet
acte aujourd'hui personne parce que
c'est des gens de trappes en dehors de
trappes d'un quartier ou d'un autre à ce
que ça arrive quoi que ce soit à voir la
traite encore les rivalités de quartier
tout ça relève du fantasme l'enquêté en
cours il faut attendre il faut patienter
il faut exiger de la police et de la
justice que les progrès arrive
rapidement
et sur la question des moyens pour
revenir sur ce que vous disiez monsieur
mbaye moi je on a dans la ville de
trappes un club de prévention
spécialisée qui est financé par le
département
les amis de l'opposition notamment
conseil municipal il dirigerait paradis
je termine a su pour dire nous avons dix
éducateurs spécialisés à trappes il nous
en faudrait 20 il nous faudrait 25 moi
je dis quelque chose sur l'année le mans
maintenant avant de conclure
on entend dire que les moyens de la
prévention spécialisée pour être réduit
à trappes je dis donc ce sera une
catastrophe c'est déjà largement
insuffisant réduire nos moyens ce serait
suicidaire merci merci là bas on avait
d'ailleurs invité la sauvegarde les
médiateurs mais bon je n'ai pas eu de
retour de leur part merci en tout cas
tous les quarts des citoyens qu est-il
oui tout à fait je dois tourner lors
d'un appel solennel il connaît les
quartiers populaires il est il a été élu
de mantes-la-jolie merci à l'érable et
merci à tous les cas elle est où les
trois pardon et le quatrième le travers
d'avoir participé à ce débat on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau circuit de société à 18h30 en
direct nous parlerons de la réforme des
collèges bonne soirée